a surprise breakthrough from the African
Union warring sides in Ethiopia have
agreed to end the Civil War the deal was
reached or signed rather by Ethiopia's
government and the tagray Liberation
Front on Wednesday the two-year conflict
in Ethiopia's Northern to gray region
has left thousands of people dead
Millions displaced and brought famine to
the region
now the deal goes beyond Justice
ceasefire and also promises to resume
desperately needed humanitarian Aid
an unexpected breakthrough after a week
of peace talks Ethiopia was set to mark
two years of war this Friday delegates
say the deal which was mediated by the
African Union is the beginning of the
end to a conflict that's seen hundreds
of thousands of people killed
at the beginning of it
that we meant to sign today
is critical
to the success of the process
the war is essentially over who has
control of the northern to gray region
both the government in Addis Ababa and
the degree people's Liberation Front
have claimed Authority both parties have
now signed off on an immediate ceasefire
after an end to hostilities negotiated
in March broke down after just five
months but there are differing
interpretations of what the agreement
means and how it will be monitored as
they signed off both sides emphasized
the importance of fully implementing the
deal
in the spirit of disagreement the people
of Ethiopia expected more than the text
of this argument our children who have
been away from schools need to go back
to schools or to
whatever is left of our schools Ethiopia
is also facing a humanitarian crisis and
famine the hope now is that this
urgently needed peace deal will hold
Samuel getachu is a journalist in the
Ethiopian Capital Addis ababind he joins
me now for more on this it's good to
have you on the program Samuel this is a
significant development tell us a little
bit more about how this agreement was
reached and does it resolve the issues
that led to the fighting in the first
place
foreign
all right I believe Samuel is back I
just want to get a sense if we can if we
can actually get back to him on the line
there or we're going to come back
all right okay
so we've been unsuccessful in
establishing that connection with Samuel
getachu in uh at this we'll see if we
can get that back uh to continue that
conversation on this deal that's been
reached to end the war in Ethiopia let's
get you now a sense of the other major
headlines uh today around the world
authorities say nearly 20 million people
could face hunger in Nigeria after
widespread flooding damaged homes
infrastructure and displaced millions of
people seasonal rains triggered severe
floods that have wiped out large swaes
of Farmland communities are struggling
to salvage remnants from this year's
Harvest
and the U.S President Joe Biden warns
that democracy in the U.S is under
attack this as he addressed the nation
ahead of next week's midterm elections
Biden called on voters and candidates to
take a stand against anyone promoting
political violence he pointed to former
president Donald Trump as the driver of
a campaign to discredit the electoral
process
a United Nations Reports say some of the
world's most famous glaciers will
disappear by 2050 due to global warming
glaciers in world heritage sites such as
the dolomites in Italy the Yosemite and
Yellowstone parks in the U.S and Mount
Kilimanjaro in Tanzania are likely to
vanish in a generation
good news we've reestablished that
connection to Samuel getichi the
journalist talking to us from Ethiopia
Sam I had just asked you the question
about the significance of this
development just tell our viewers a
little bit about how the agreement was
reached and and does it resolve the
issues that led to the fighting in the
first place
here's a big achievement in terms of uh
where this was headed a few days ago the
Ethiopian Prime Minister was saying
they've been put under pressure by
Western Nations to agree to compromise
on some of the disagreements they've
been having with the tplf the Ethiopian
government has been assisting the tplf
is a terrorist organization that they're
dealing they're being forced to deal
with a terrorist organization so to see
Gita Radha who represented the tplf and
also the Ethiopian side represented by
the advisor to the Prime Minister radwan
Hussein is a big achievement by itself
but how it's going to be implemented is
the question that needs to be answered
in the days to come
so so what are the next steps now uh
speaking about the implementation where
do things go from here
well um as the head of the delegation of
the TPL level there hasn't been any
school open for the young people of uh
Tegra as well as amhara and afar and
there has to be an establishment of the
banking sector that has been closed
since uh for a year now especially in
tegray so there has to be a system to
reopen the region of tegrai and bring it
back to where it was because as you
mentioned previously even famine is
becoming a reality again not just
Integra but also in amhara and afar so
the government is expected to lay out a
foundation where this would lead the
country in the days and weeks uh forward
and how much confidence is there that
this deal will hold and and that the war
is is now really over
well you know the Ethiopian government
and the TPL have had signed an agreement
now when you implement it you know there
has been at least 600 000 people that
have died uh all over Ethiopia since
this conflict begun so it's there's no
there has to be some kind of system to
let Ethiopians understand that the
country the nation of Ethiopia is moving
forward and they're not going to look
forward but there has to be a system to
understand exactly what happened and how
to address some of the misgivings of the
victims and they're not just in the
hundreds and thousands they're in the
millions millions three million
Ethiopians have been displaced as a
result as a result of this conflict and
there has to be the government has to be
able to answer it somehow but the
question is will Ethiopia have enough
resources to investigate exactly what
happened so the nation could move
forward
all right that's Samuel get it you're
talking to us from the Ethiopian Capital
but thank you Samuel